[Music]
difficult with all the glitches
but it it ended up being pretty good
i definitely prefer it this way though
um i didn't like
virtual you didn't no it was terrible
sometimes when this video is like paying
attention to something else
you could eat if you're like really
tired then we could be nothing a little
bit
frustrated students telling president
biden how they feel about remote
learning today but complaints like those
are
apparently being ignored instead a new
report suggests the biden administration
allowed a powerful teachers union to
influence school reopening guidelines
emails first reported by the new york
post show frequent communication
between top cdc officials and the
american federation of teachers
in at least two instances the union
offered up language
suggestions that were reportedly adopted
nearly verbatim into the final text of
the document
that the cdc put out both the cdc and
the teachers union say this type of
communication is just routine
the union telling fox news quote the aft
represents 1.7 million
educators healthcare professionals and
public employees who spent the last 14
months
serving on the front lines of the covet
19 pandemic so naturally we have been in
regular touch with the agency setting
policy
that affect their work and lives
including
the cdc so there hasn't been a foia
hall like this since maybe the uh
hillary clinton emails that came out and
during that campaign
um jesse i'm going to give you
permission to make any sort of analogy
i'm assuming
that you have one i don't but now i feel
like there's this expectation that i
need to have an analogy and i had a
great one
would you like to repeat it no go ahead
okay i do find it funny that the cdc
says there was no political interference
at the same time smoking documents show
political interference and i'm just
wondering if you have to be a liar to
work for the government
or the government makes you a liar i
just don't know
right now it looks like politics is
cinema
these teachers union have to act scared
they have to act
reticent to come back and that's how
they get paid and that's what happened
here because there was no risk
and that's not me saying there was no
risk the new york times says there was
no risk and i'm sick of the new york
times
saying the same thing i've been saying
except months later and then my mom
calls me and say did you see jesse
what the new york times said yeah mom i
know
they said today the risk is minuscule to
children
minuscule they said children don't
really catch it quote it's not even
contagious there
and they said hybrid learning is hurting
and that not opening
schools up fully hurts the economy and
it hurts working
women the most so i don't know they're
johnny come lately to that but also dana
where's the republican party when you
showed the video
of dr jill and the president in a
classroom
hearing from students say how this
democrat policy just destroyed their
lives this year
why hasn't a republican senator or
congressman held a press conference at a
school like that
i mean that would have been big i mean
do i have to do all of the heavy lifting
around here
the worst part about the whole story
though in the research packet which i
read today
it said well biden isn't certain schools
are going to be open this fall because
you know
he doesn't have a crystal ball but at
the same
breath he says if we don't spend a
trillion dollars on green energy
he knows the earth's temperature to a
degree in a hundred years
i i don't it's hard to square those
let's take a look at that
sam this is anita dunn the president's i
think our senior counselor
on school's reopening in the fall
he said probably he didn't say
absolutely but
given the science if the vaccination
program in this country proceeds
if people do go get their vaccines
there he does believe that schools
should be able to reopen
in september and reopen safely following
the cdc guidelines
but he said probably but one if i were a
parent
and my kids weren't in school i would
pull my hair out at an answer like that
because remember the teachers were
allowed to go to the front of the line
to get the vaccine
but they still said they wouldn't go
back to the classroom
yeah i think it's a much bigger issue
than just the teachers though i mean in
my opinion biden's going to have a big
problem if the schools aren't open in
the fall i think there's going to be a
big
fallout economically picking up on
jesse's point about working women
with children need schools open in order
for them to get back to work and i also
need daycare and the like
so i think there's a problem now the
caveat that i would add here
is i don't think it's just up to the
government i think a lot of it's up to
us as the american people
we still have a lot of people who won't
get vaccinated
and you know that's on them that's not
on the president so if you're in a
community
you know given that we're now at the
point where there's more vaccine than
demand for vaccine
if you live in a community dana where
let's say 30 or 40 percent
of the community is vaccinated meaning
60 or 70 percent
is not uh that might be a problem if
you're a teacher
uh because it means that there is still
you know a spread
potential spread of the contagion in
your district in your neighborhood but
if you as a teacher
are vaccinated then it would just be i'm
saying that the
cd the cdc says i think right now it's
like 30 percent of us
have been uh have had two shots okay so
we're fully vaccinated i would hope that
the teachers are that way
but i can see you know you know this
this whole argument
about unions i think is bogus because if
you're an electrician a plumber
a firefighter a policeman or a teacher
your union's job
is to represent you and a conservative
watchdog group says oh look at these
emails
guess what they're all these unions put
pressure on politicians give money to
politicians
you may disagree with the teachers but
to demonize them like that's not fair
i don't know greg i don't know anybody
that's demonizing teachers the
the cdc took language directly from the
teachers union and put it in the
guidance
they waited two weeks to put out the
guidance because they said remember
wolinski the woman who runs the cdc said
in her personal capacity
the kids could go back to school that's
what the white house said oh that was
her personal capacity but actually we
know now because based on these emails
she actually really did believe that but
then she waited for this guidance based
on i imagine
some political pressure and then pulled
her personal opinion
back yeah the uh one brought up the
other unions and it's a really
actually kind of an interesting point
they aren't doing this uh
they mentioned that uh the teachers were
for the past i don't know
16 months or whatever we're in the front
lines no it was those other it was the
police
and the fire department the people
delivering our food the people that work
at the supermarkets
they're the ones that are doing all the
work that are keeping us and the media
fat you know and we can sit here and
make comments because
all these other people are working and
not complaining and yet there's only one
union that is standing out and i
after a while you start wondering what
is going on with them because
it's like if you've ever been uh
involved in a deal
and every time when you're trying to buy
a house or you're trying to buy a car
and this person keeps raising objections
every step of the way it suddenly dawns
on you that they don't
want it to happen they actually are
doing everything possible
just to string you along until you give
up because i don't understand this
all the problems that we basically face
right now have to do with teachers
unions
the fact that there's no competition in
poor or lower income neighborhoods
that's teachers unions these students
are stuck with one choice
uh and they're holding all the marbles
so it's like imagine having only one
cable provider
how that sucks you know we would never
stand for that but somehow we're totally
cool
with these poor neighborhoods having
absolutely no competition
and so this is the consequence is that
you can't do anything
people aren't if they they there's no
option for them
we have to change this we have to use
this crisis and by the way this is
another crisis
the biden now has two major crises but
no one wants to use the c word with him
if it was trump they would call it a
crisis
but right now we are we are playing down
huge issues uh because
it's a teachers union who have inserted
themselves into this into this process
because they can why can they why do
they have the power
i don't understand this katie i just
want to show this graphic real quickly
this is
um gender equality in school and how the
lack of normal schooling is hurting
mothers so
you see there in terms of women with
young kids
not being able to get back to work right
and you wonder for a white house like
this
who wins out the women or the teachers
union
well the teachers union and big
government proponents so now they're
extorting
even more money again by saying well if
we want women to get back in the
workplace we have to pass this new human
infrastructure bill to the tune of
almost two trillion dollars
in order for women to go back to work
while they ignore the fact that they
have allowed the teachers unions to
control
now we know cdc guidance when it comes
to kids going back to school dana if you
look at the dates
okay so february 3rd was when dr
wolenski came out during an
official white house press conference on
covid and said
teachers do not have to be vaccinated
for teachers to go back to school safely
the next day jen stockey comes out and
says she was speaking in her personal
capacity
and now we know that's because they were
allowing teachers unions to
guide the science that were that they
claimed that they were following
when it comes to school reopenings and
so they're following the money here they
used to say
that we had to pass the covid relief
bill which was two trillion dollars
in order for teachers to get back in
classrooms so that they could pay for
ventilation
they could safely get back to school
well that passed so now they're saying
well if you want women to get back in
the workplace
you have to pass another human
infrastructure bill for government paid
child care so this is all about growing
the government expanding the government
and for dr jill biden to go to that
school today as a teacher
who claims that she cares about kids and
to listen to that and not come out and
say
teachers unions are holding these kids
hostage they're holding
their families hostage and they need to
get back to school is
pretty cowardly considering that she
claims
to stand up for the best interests of
her students she has more
in terms of responsibility here than a
lot of first ladies do
the teachers union actually broke
records in terms of the political
donations that it made in the first
quarter of this year hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else